[Music]
foreign
that's glaringly apparent I can't fail
this class oh don't sell yourself short
Mr Coates I truly believe that you can
every year at Barton Academy students
faculty and staff depart the campus for
a two-week winter break but there are
always an unfortunate few who have
nowhere to go for the holidays they're
known as the holdovers Mr Hannah hello
Mary I had you got stuck with
babysitting duty this year how did you
manage that you know it used to be a
student right that's why he knows how to
inflict maximum pain on them
[Music]
son of a [__] that's another detention
do you think I want to be babysitting
you no I was praying your mother would
pick up the phone or your father would
arrive in a helicopter or a flying
saucer your father is dead
you don't tell a boy that's been left
behind at Christmas that nobody wants
him what's wrong with you there's nobody
here okay you stay out of my way and
I'll stay out of yours let me sleep
most of the kids dislike you pretty much
hate you teachers too you know that
right I find the world a bitter and
complicated place and it seems to feel
the same way about me I think you and I
have this in common
I don't think I've ever had a real
family Christmas like this before
thank you Mary you're welcome history is
not simply the study of the past it is
an explanation of the present see when
you say it that way and throw in some
pornography it's a lot easier to
understand
I'd like to propose a toast to my two
unlikely companions
are you trying to look down my shirt
yes you're gonna get me fired this is
your Rubicon do not cross
the holdovers
[Music]
oh